i want to start with how much and i'm
going to drop this word how much i
[ __ ] loved this movie
it is fantastic
i i can't say enough good things about
this film talked a while not too long
ago and i
i had a feeling you were gonna like it i
told you you were gonna lie yeah this
film's on another level
um i need to know uh who ruined the most
takes from laughing at this dialogue
yeah well i think we're all guilty here
i don't want to
you know i don't want to assume
responsibility but i think we're all
guilty flulaborg
uh you know he's a contender but but i
think
john definitely took the prize i mean
there was like there was a there i think
there was a
uh instituted a phrase like the you know
we'll do a john take you know like let's
just let john have a take and like get
that [ __ ] out of his system
and uh and he would let her rip we had a
lot of fun
so much darkness inside that man so
what actual perversion and darkness just
i think
it was a therapeutic for him he just
needed to like let it out
one of the things that i love about this
script is the way it takes these
unexpected
left turns yeah um just every scene
is an unexpected left turn for both of
you
um what was your favorite part about uh
james's writing
the overall confidence and handle that
that he has on this genre and
he he just allows himself to swing so
big you know
it's like it's so silly at times it's
really childish humor and then and then
it's really gory violent and and then
at the same time he finds these little
moments of
emotional sincerity that that
you know when i saw the film i think
that was what i was most impressed
by personally was how effortless and
unforced and
you know unpretentious they felt that
you know
so i think to be able to encompass all
of that into one
film it just makes it for such a wild
experience
he's certainly extremely uh descriptive
and the fact that he
writes uh directs at its produces he's
in every phase
along the way i think that helps bring
forth his vision
um man i really do enjoy the the
commitment to mythology as well the
suicide squad is a cast of expendables
and i really appreciate like the fact
that we get to know these people in
their journey and we
we invest in the importance and the
fragility of life
with expendable characters that will die
and i think that explains a lot of the
left-hand turns but like
it's the suicide squad it's very
apparent
on what you're getting into and it's we
it's a weird conundrum
and there's so many ways you can look at
the film but like life is precious
but it also these guys are expendable
and i think that it's
it's really cool how james leaned into
that i love learning about the stuff
that
you
can't read in the press notes what do
you think might surprise people to learn
about the making of the suicide squad
speaking for me
how it's just it's it's probably won't
surprise me it's a fun movie to make
here we are in this massive shoot uh
warner brothers
you know biggest shoot ever it's a it's
a a
price a pricey movie to make a long
shoot
never once did it feel arduous at all
i mean we had a great group of folks and
never once was it a struggle never once
was it
even challenging in any sort of way the
toughest thing i had to do was eat
empanadas dude
like that's honestly that's like my
takeaway of like ah those empanadas
right like that's
that's my that's my tough day at work
like it really that was
yeah that was the day it just was uh it
was struggling a little bit that day and
it was
it was one one day when we really
you know we're trying to get this whole
very convoluted scene
in one take and and it was just a lot of
movement and dialogue that had to come
in the right time
and i mean i mean i had i had my share
of misses as well
but the whole scene started with john
eating like four empanadas
and since we were getting gonna get it
in one tank
you know at the end of it he was like
honestly leave everyone such a qualifier
that i honestly believe they kind of got
together ahead of time be like yo let's
[ __ ] with john
and that's okay that's all right i don't
mind being the butt of the joke and i
got to eat street food all day so it's
pretty cool
gentlemen i have to go i'm just going to
say how much i'm also looking forward to
peacemaker
and for all mankind season 3 which is
one of the best shows on tv if you're
not watching
you need to watch thank you so much man
thank you so much